I am one of the the people I continuum
who built packages and I also work on
the tooling at continuum to build
packages and I was going to come here
and tell you guys today about all the
stuff that goes wrong with packaging and
in talking with some of you in the
hallway it really became clear that it
would be better if I just showed you how
to do packaging from the get-go and not
show you all the squirrely stuff that
can happen that makes my life fun so
we're going to talk about kind of the
anatomy of a package and how to start
one from nothing and then I'm going to
show you Conda build which is the tool
that I work on to help make some of this
stuff easier and if we have time I'll
show you guys a little bit about what
we're doing at continuing to try to
automate our builds and make it scalable
we currently provide about 700 packages
but pie-pie has about 80,000 packages of
course that's a really long tail of
packages that don't get used but keeping
up with the ecosystem is a hard problem
and it's something that we're working on
and we won't we won't get to the the
squirrely stuff I'm sorry so you want to
make a package let's talk first about
what exactly a package is what I'm going
to call it two different things most of
the time when I'm talking about a
package it's some kind of file that
you're going to ship around that has
stuff that you want people to be able to
install some kinds of packages like
Python packages are our files but they
have formalisms to say where the file
should go so that Python knows what to
do with them right there's also the term
a Python package which means like a
folder that has Python modules in it and
in that name overloading kind of yet
it's unfortunate so I'll try to be clear
here where I'm talking about package
types as files and if you have package
files you might be familiar with s disks
or wheels
those are things you'll see on pi PI IPI
I deal mostly in condo packages which
are dot RB z2 file that has a
particularly out
and to produce one of those you you
always start with well if you're dealing
with Python you start with a Python
package and so who here has made their
own Python package anybody a few people
did you use a standard layout you found
some where did you just kind of wing it
yeah tutorial tutorials great this might
be even better than a tutorial so cookie
cutter is up like a template generator
thing and I'll just show you their
website it's a Python installable
library and when you install it you can
then run the cookie cutter for any given
kind of project that you're going to
start ok so if I go over here and I
start a a real quick docker container
that just has mini Conda installed I can
just say pip install cookie cutter
and then a cookie cutter I'm going to go
to one of these to a particular repo I
have here oops so we've made this
particular template for condo projects
and so it just goes through this
interactive dialogue is this make this
bigger not big enough you go through
this interactive dialogue you say oh my
name is Michael and email address
whatever github username and this is
this is filling in blanks in that
package template so that what you get
out is now this this llama folder that
I've created that has that nice standard
layout you would get from a tutorial and
if you take a look at what's in setup
pie it's kind of set you up for just
kind of a generic thing that you can
build on okay so if you have existing
code this is still useful it's kind of
showing you the model and you can copy
and paste stuff into this model of stuff
all right
to actually build a package with this
you can just say I think it's hip pick
wheel dot right and so that just built a
wheel for my package there similarly
because this conduct this this
particular cookie cutter template of
ours is made for a condo recipe what's
in that condo dot recipe folder is a
meta dot yamo file which is the input to
condo build for us to build a condo
package so I can say condo build condo
dot recipe and it's going to tell me I
don't have condo build installed not a
problem
kondeh install condo build
and if we do that now so what you'll
notice is that condo bill is going to
have a whole boatload more output and
it's because condo build is a more
complicated tool what it's doing is its
leveraging conda's ability to create
environments and it's creating the build
environment for the package and it can
create any number of different
configurations so it does that it runs
the building that thing is then detects
what files have changed in its build
prefix where it's created the
environment that's what it kind of
considers as files to package and after
that it runs a test phase where it
installs the package that it's created
and makes sure that it works for you
okay
so compared to wheels Conda recipes and
kind of packages are totally language
agnostic
it is totally all about this this UNIX
kind of file system layout and so the
the output package here goes to the mini
Conda Conda Conda build Linux 64 folder
here and if we take a look at what's
actually in that that file we've got a
whole bunch of metadata that tells Conda
about what's going on in that file and
how to deal with it we've got the Python
files that got recorded and pre compiled
for stuff and then here's we've got the
entry point but you see this is this is
very imitative of something that you
would see as like slash e.t.c e.t.c lib
slash user whatever that's kind of how
it works and the fundamental key to
akanda package is as long as you kind of
it will create the build prefix as long
as you move stuff where you want it in
that build prefix it'll get packaged and
so if you've ever fought setup tools to
include files outside of Python setup
tools is great with dealing with Python
files but dealing with like data files
it has caused me great pain and in
comparison a condor recipe lets you just
simply move something into that prefix
file and so if i say here go back to my
recipe and a bt get stalled in
hip
so this part doesn't have the this well
this does have the build instructions in
it if I comment this out I can also have
a separate file that then can do
anything and so we can say echo llama
and then there's there's a few important
predefined environment variables so
dollar sign prefix is going to always
point to that build prefix or if it's in
the test environment it's going to point
to the test prefix but this is all you
need to do to actually install files
into a condom package and have condom
know what to do with them okay so we've
seen a condom build I'll skip over that
one other quick and easy way to create
condor recipes is to we've we've made
skeleton generators and so we know that
there's these other repositories that
have boatloads of really great content
on them and we want to make it easy to
to bring those into the
kondeh ecosystem and so if you I'm going
to go ahead and create a skeleton here
for beautifulsoup for so I know it's on
pi PI I say beautifulsoup for here
this is going to go look on pipe I get
the metadata read the setup I file
information from that file and come up
with a recipe for us and so here's our
folder with the recipe in it and we've
got that build a sage folder and
metadata yeah no build that Sh
a lot of the time is really nothing more
than just saying Python set up that PI
install and if that's all you have you
can roll that into the metadata ya know
which is what I showed you guys before
from our template but you see here it's
just gone to PI pi recorded all that
information gets you the md5 and it
makes your life a whole lot easier to
start out from something from PI pi
okay so we've got the same thing for
cran and Sipan and we just recently
added support for rpms if you need to
what we're what we're moving towards
more and more is having really low level
system packages and so people had been
moving towards building things like x11
and it that's just it's really hard and
it ends up giving you like really poor
hardware acceleration capabilities so
what we're trying to move towards
instead is to encourage people to
rebuttal the operating system level
packages and use those as they as they
see fit all right what I've shown you is
a gross oversimplification and if
there's ever been a part of programming
where there's been more edge cases I
haven't seen it yet so every given
package takes special love especially
when you have compiled content in there
and another big thing is how do you keep
all of your dependencies in mind how do
you keep them compatible so you don't
want to be too restrictive and you also
don't want to be too loose with your
constraints if you're too restrictive
then you unnecessarily
meaning that other packages can't play
nicely with you and at the same time if
you're to lose things can change out
from under you and your software breaks
so I'll show you guys a little bit more
about that we've added a new feature in
our latest version to kondeh build
that's really exciting once you have
your own package there's a lot of
different places to put it
so everybody's probably familiar with pi
PI who knows about anaconda org a few
people yeah so anaconda org is
Continuum's community repository people
get free channels by themselves and you
can put your own packages there as much
as you want
so unlike pi PI where somebody can kind
of lay down a claim to to a package and
kind of have this namespace battle of
who is the actual owner of a package it
doesn't matter
on anaconda org right you you are you
and anybody can install from your
channel and you manage what's there so
yeah I've found it very refreshing and
what has really been incredible to see
is the community that has grown around
anaconda org so people have recognized
how powerful that that kind of ability
to have your own channel and your own
really purpose-built
channel is and there's been several
communities of people who have come
together and they each have their own
way of building packages but they end up
uploading them to anaconda org so by
akanda does all kinds of biology related
stuff DNA sequencing and stuff I don't
understand
omnia was molecular dynamics mento is
computer vision and so what this what
this means is that even if continuum
doesn't have a package for you you can
say anaconda search what you're looking
for and a lot of the times somebody on
one of these other channels will have
built it and that's pretty awesome the
biggest community by far is one called
Conda Forge and
this has been just a unifying effort so
they have a really nice CI type setup
where you submit a recipe it builds
tries to build a package and when your
PR is merged it becomes part of this
giant aggregate repository of other
recipes so I would really strongly
encourage you guys to check out their
website and also if you if you're using
Conda and you can't find a package the
first place to look is kata forge as I
said we've got about 700 in our
repository they've got 2600 and and
they're growing fast and we're a part of
them to be honest so we have I
participate in Conda fors and we have
two or three other people that help with
it so it's really nice to see that grow
one other I guess kind of silly fun
trivia thing to show you here this is
what I want to show you I'm pretty sure
this is the the organization on github
with the most number of repositories
because what happens is every single
recipe becomes its own repository and so
this organization has two thousand six
hundred and forty four plus a few repos
on it and and that has a consolidated
view that gets automatically generated
once in a while called feedstocks it's
all corny and blacksmithing themed but
uh yeah so you just see here these are
all sub modules and github refuses to
show you anywhere close to all of them
so when we started seeing this it was a
was a fun day
so I mentioned that there's a lot of
ways that things can break there are
some things we can control as packagers
and a lot of stuff we can't and so when
it comes to these three things API is is
the actual code in a program and that's
you know people may change arguments
that may change return types they may
change
input types all kinds of stuff that's
obviously going to break you ABI is more
subtle that comes about due to like what
compiler you use or what OS you're on
when you build something you get you get
these binary symbols that may or may not
be supported on other people's computers
who has tried to install tensorflow
from pi pi and had it not work okay
this was your problem because Google was
evil when they published it and there is
a standard for for publishing wheels on
pi PI for Linux and that standard says
that you have to build your
compatibility back to this old OS Santos
5 now they did not do that they built on
a newer system and they did not make it
compatible but they labeled it many
Linux 1 compatible anyway so give them a
hard time if you see anybody yeah
finally constraints are both they're
both a way to make stuff work but
they're also a way to make it break so
they are the part that we really have
control over to help make sure that
things work as far as ABI compatibility
it's boring
there's not a lot of secret to it it's
just a matter of laying down good
standards of what your worker machines
are going to be in understanding the
limits of those worker machines and yeah
the hard part is that those worker
machines it's really hard to make
everybody happy because you've got some
people in your organization who
stability is the ultimate goal and we
have to stay on CentOS 5 you got other
people saying I want to use C++ 14
how do you do both it's hard and the
answer is not always good so on Windows
it's really boring we just follow up
stream and so upstream says Python - 7 s
built with Visual Studio 2008 that's
what we do and as a result we can't
support things that are done with C++ 11
for Python - 7 on Windows so in that
case we sometimes patch packages to
remove C++ 11 there's there's some idea
it's been like a really hotly debated
thing to build Python 2 7 with a
different compiler but it's really hairy
and there's really not much support from
upstream so that doesn't seem like it's
going to happen any time soon
Mac OS is boring also you use the right
SDK when it comes to Fortran we ship GCC
packages but also include gfortran
that's just a little bit tricky because
clang + + is not binary compatible with
G + + yeah good times
Linux is finally the most interesting
and we've gotten really really far by
building on CentOS 5 with the newest
compiler that was available there so if
you've used anaconda for the past three
or four years this has been what it's
been built with now this is also the
many Linux people kind of reverse
engineered this and this is also their
standard they build with a slightly new
compiler I'll talk about in a bit but we
really hit a lot of problems with this
because we're not getting any of the
performance or security improvements
that have come out of newer compilers
so what you really want to do on Linux
in order to build a package that's as
good in terms of compatibility and
performance as it can be you want to
build on as old of a Linux distribution
as you can tolerate and so for example
where you cease to be able to tolerate
it is where the kernel symbols have
changed too much and you start to have
trouble with stuff that builds against
the kernel symbols tensorflow for
example don't try to do it on CentOS 5
which is coincidentally why
Google didn't try to do it on CentOS
five right yeah for those of you guys
following along this is the most
fantastic website describing what you
should do for this process that's got
the reasons why it works and a very very
good article so really what you want to
be able to do is custom build your own
compiler or pull one in from somewhere
else that's newer and use it on an
ancient OS so the many linux guys have a
docker image that does exactly that they
use CentOS 5 and they have this Red Hat
dev tool set compiler that's
specifically patched a lot by Red Hat to
maintain this backwards compatibility is
also what Khanda Forge uses one of our
experts ray Donnelly who's famous for
doing a lot of the emphasis to project
he just doesn't trust that and so we're
kind of wary of this we don't have any
hard evidence against anything he's
queasy about it so we tried to custom
build a new GCC into a CentOS 5 docker
image I did GCC 5.2 and it just had too
many strange issues and I tried to make
it multi Lib so that the 64 bit compiler
could compile 32-bit code and nobody was
really happy anyway what we're doing now
is we are making Khanda packages for the
compilers these are built with a tool
called cross tool ng which is the
absolute coolest tool ever for for
creating portable tool chains it
includes both the kernel headers and G
Lib C or muscle Lib C or any other Lipsy
you want and because it encompasses all
those things they no longer matters what
build platform you're on so it gives us
really tremendous freedom to to use
whatever other build platform is
convenient for any other reason and it
comes at the cost of we need to ship
lips standard C++ people have to use our
live standard C++ because
our compiler is so new so Lib standard
C++ is totally backwards compatible but
if you build on a to new of a compiler
and you have an ancient lip standard C++
you're going to have these binary
symbols that and aren't available all
right you can imagine this has caused a
lot of headache to people over the years
and it's been wonderful that that our
platform has been so standard for a long
time but because people are wanting to
change and wanting to adapt to newer
compilers we have to figure out a way to
solve this and it really comes down to
the informations there you actually have
to record it and you've got to use it to
make decisions so our term for this
entirely is CD T stands for core
dependency tree and kind of builds going
to start recording this kind of stuff
it's just all the information related to
the compiler that was used for your
system and all the stuff that's going to
affect its bounds of compatibility and
and then more for informational purposes
things like the compiler flags all right
what Conda will do with this is because
it's embedded in the condom package
itself you will be able to specify to
Conda or even have Conda detect what
your system is compatible with so if
you're saying oh I'm on a sin toxic
system I cannot use anything that's
built with a G Lib C newer than 2.12 and
Conda can then make recommendations to
you to say oh well you know this package
is uninstalled will because this or it
can also say oh you're actually running
a new OS and we can turn on these extra
optimizations so it's going to give us a
lot of flexibility to make things work
better when it comes to you guys writing
recipes just a tiny bit of advice
avoid constraints as much as you can and
keep your recipes as general as you can
and so what I see a lot of the time is
especially people coming from the pit
world writing requirements txt files
with exact pins
exact pins are fine as long as you're
creating an environment but if you are
installing two packages with two
separate requirements files and they
each have different equals equals
constraints what do you think happens
it should blow up but it doesn't pip has
actually really strange rules and it's
kind of like the first one in wins yeah
so we just released Cana built three
this morning and this has been about a
year's a year-long effort to to cram
Jinja to and do as many corners as I
could into a condo build because what
what we allow through templating is we
allow all of that pinning stuff to be
done dynamically and later and from
external sources so something like condo
forage can have a canonical copy of a
recipe that doesn't define any versions
at all but then somebody else can define
a separate outside file that map's their
own CDT or or whatever you want to call
it so there is an icon notebook I'd like
to just run through real quick with you
guys and show you some of the new
features here this is also a blog post
that's gone out this morning if you want
to look at it check our check
Continuum's developer blog page and what
this is going to show you is Conda
rendering which means it takes that
input meta demo file and then does stuff
to it fills in templates yet does does
the selectors which are running
particular lines or not and I'll show
you just the the extra flexibility here
so this is the Jinja template syntax for
hey it's a variable here and I've got my
config file that is just dead simple
yeah Mille and it's a list of values and
what's going to happen is kind of build
is going to put in those values for each
of those template things
so here it's rendering what the actual
output files would be and here's what
the actual recipes would be
so you see it's done the pinning okay
kind of cute so this works for Python
versions it works for numpy versions
works for anything
one thing I'll point out about Conda
build is it really tries to enhance
reproducibility and so what it's doing
when you render a recipe to build it is
it's saying exactly what was in the
build environment so that you're able to
then rebuild exactly that recipe based
on whatever was in the past even if
there's new versions of stuff that has
come out since yeah if you guys I'm
going to skip that that's just saying
that the old way of doing things still
works but well the other interesting
thing is whatever you build has this new
thing is it's a it looks a lot like a
git pash because it for all intents and
purposes is kind of a good hash it is
formed by all kinds of important
information about your recipe and what
it gives us is the ability to
differentiate those variants on disk in
a totally generic way and so the old way
was to say oh well your is it's Python
and so when you have Python that that
gets added to the file name some similar
up here right you get PI to 7mp whatever
that does not scale all right what if
you have G del 1 and G del 2 so that's
what the the hashes are for and then
there's a way which I skipped over here
to have it tell you what what actually
went into that hash because it's pretty
obscure right H whatever doesn't tell
you anything about what went into it so
this is kind of primitive at this point
but it's the kind of thing where we can
probably build a library query tool to
say
tell me all the packages that meet this
condition all right one other thing is
we've enabled pinning to be relative and
so what you would see in a requirement
txt file is just simply some text and
what you see now in Conda build is it's
going to say what version of Lib PNG did
I have at Build time and let me express
some constraint based on that version so
the way that this works is there are
default arguments to it so if I just say
pin compatible to Lib PNG it's going to
look for lid PNG up in the build
requirements and here it's found oh look
I had version 1 627 the default way of
doing this penning expression is as many
places of precision as you have in the
version number for the lower one and
then the next major version so this is
totally customizable you can change the
max pin to be like two places right and
then it increments that last place you
can also get rid of them or or specify
exact values and so if you specify any
of them as none it's going to say we'll
just leave that constraint out
completely so we have no min pin and if
we say the upper bound is 5
that totally overrides any of the
relative pinning one other thing that's
really key to kondeh build 3 is we want
to enable people to use dynamic
compilers and dynamic compiler settings
and so if you move away from the thought
of like oh I need a compiler configured
on my system you don't you just need to
tell kind of build how to get a compiler
or how to set one up and so if you're
using these em SVC things
kondeh build has in the past run the
activate script for you it'll still do
that if you want but but we're moving
towards this you will make a package or
you will use a package that
politically defined your settings and
this is fantastic because people will be
able to just so Intel for example is
really excited they want to use their
Intel compiler to build all this stuff
right but they don't want to hack that
into condo build now they don't have to
they just have to use recipes that are
built for this compiler metadata and
then configure in their kind of build
configure know what the exact compiler
is and that's it so it's just tremendous
flexibility and yeah so there you see
it's it's rendered in different
compilers one other kind of cute thing
and then I'll be done here is that
people oftentimes forget or don't know
what their actual dependencies are and
so what kind of build three frees people
up to do is it frees up the pinning the
the actual addition of the constraints
to the package creators to the upstream
package creators rather than the
downstream person using the package and
we're what we're hoping this is going to
iron out is a lot of missing
dependencies on shared objects at
runtime and especially live standard C++
because people are really used to that
one being on the system so anyway we've
got a recipe it's doing this thing
called run exports and it is exporting
something compatible with whatever we
have it build time and we also have a
recipe that's just going to use that and
we're going to build the first one
keep it here locally and when we when we
see what would be fully rendered for
that second one it has inserted that
newbie zip to requirement based on using
this package has run exports here so
really hopeful that will turn out if it
blows up in our faces there is a way to
turn it off so please play with it and
be very curious to know what you think
I guess I have a little bit of time for
this we have not had a CI system for
packaging and so we we script everything
of course but it requires us to like SSH
or B and C or RDP or whatever into some
build worker and build stuff and that
manual tedium is just terrible so we've
set out to create a CI system and we
needed to be cross-platform we want
people to be able to volunteer machines
as workers and we also want this thing
we've got hundreds or thousands of
recipes we can only build what changed
we don't want to build the whole system
all the time that's totally intractable
and that's what has killed earlier
efforts so we experimented with a lot of
CI tools and settled on concourse C I
which was started by pivotal the really
great thing about this is it's totally
based on ya know files and that you can
dynamically create pipelines from
pipelines and so our process somebody
will commit recipe changes and then we
have a job on the CI service and this is
kind of a static job it's computing what
the build system should do what recipes
should be built it submits a new
pipeline and that's what this looks like
in concourse these are jobs nothing
fancy just it gets this stuff from from
up above and then runs the examination
process and our sinks the recipes
elsewhere and it creates these really
cool-looking you know build trees and so
this is kind of what goes into mini
Khanda yeah thank you
this is what goes into mini conda it's
just the basic fundamentals but it's
also Python 2 7 and 3 6 for just CentOS
as this thing goes along things light up
like Christmas trees they go green when
they're good to go red when they're bad
but it's a lot of fun to watch and it's
it's also amazing because each
these things are totally separate
processes and massively scalable right
each of those nodes can can do a job and
so we're hoping that that's a major boon
for us this is also much better at doing
testing so we've got a dag we can
navigate that dag dag is directed
acyclic graph to do much better testing
so we can say well whenever we rebuild
numpy make sure you also test
Saiki I damaged so I could learn
whatever make sure that the core stuff
doesn't break
so thanks this is my team and they're
great and thank you all for listening
thanks Michael question
[Applause]
so I'm a bit new to conduct been
following it for the last three years or
so but haven't actually been using it
until this conference so my question was
is it appears with a really compelling
case for it is to be able to deal with
binary and Python version and
compatibility across the systems which
is why I was attending this talk I came
away a little bit terrified from what I
just saw so is there anything that you
can say that would help us understand
the issues with regard to binary
compatibility and stuff going forward
I'm not sure I'm coming tell me tell me
what terrifies you because it's I've
certainly said that it's a lot of awful
work but there's never been a better
time to dig into it because Khan DeForge
especially is this monumental source of
knowledge with really really great
volunteers who will help you sort
through things and so if you submit a
recipe to Khan DeForge you will
absolutely end up you know having it
work and learning a lot ok so basically
it's really the community that we've got
this really dynamic good community that
we've known and loved for years here and
that's going to help us help me be able
to go ahead and use the system to be
able to deal with these moles or well
did the technical issue of binary
compatibility is one that's not new at
all you know yeah right that this has
not changed and the only thing that's
making it harder is that we're kind of
at a crossroads where we're C++ 11 and
14 have improved the situation enormous
Lee but they require modernization of
your stack and they there's just rivers
you've got across fair enough thank you
there
get my exercise this way thank you
question about missing dependencies so I
saw the there's kind of this clever idea
of picking up whatever is on the machine
at build time and then generating your
dependency file based on that it wasn't
clear to me how you knew which
dependencies actually mattered and which
were noise so for reproducibility I
would argue that they all matter you
want to be able to recreate the same
package at a later date and I think it's
an intractable problem to say I want to
figure out which one of these really
matter so am I actually linking against
these if - or is that a trivial thing
that Python is bringing in that's that's
I don't think it's worth the effort got
it so there's no static analysis or
anything you're literally just saying
hey anything that's on the machine on
the build machine could affect the final
product so let's just take it not quite
so it's not on the build machine it is
the build prefix itself and so it's to
say I asked Conda hey here are my specs
what are you going to install for these
specs for the build environment got it
yeah if you ever get system stuff in
your package you're going to have a bad
time and so that's one thing that that
kind of really pretty good for is the
system isolation and keeping your
packages pure and that means you're more
confident that they're going to work on
the other end